اذا الياس مؤتمر صحفي حمل العديد من
التصريحات ادلى بها نتنياهو في هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي وهناك ايضا وامور جرت قبل
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي يتعلق باتساع شقه
الخلاف حتى داخل مجلس
الحرب يبدو كذلك لان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يوف جلنت رفض حضور هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي ومشاركته مع رئيس الوزراء بن
نتنياهو وهكذا فعل ايضا الوزير بيني جانس
عضو مجلس الحرب وواضح بان هنالك شقاق
بينهما وخلاف ما بين اعضاء مجلس الحرب
فيما يتعلق اولا بالرؤيه ومساله البحث في
ما سيكون عليه الحال في قطاع غزه ما بعد
الحرب والجهه التي ستتولى مسؤوليه اداره
شؤونه ربما ايضا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
يوف جلاند غاضب على بنيامين نتنياهو الذي
منع منعه من عقد اجتماعات عات بحضور رئيسي
المساد والشباك رغم ان بنيامين نتنياهو
نفى ذلك في المؤتمر الصحفي وواضح ان ايضا
بيني جانس يسعى الى مساله مناقشه قضيه ما
بعد الحرب وبنيامين نتنياهو لا يريد ذلك
رضوخا للضغوط التي يتعرض لها من الجناح
المتطرف في حكومته وزير الماليه بيتسل ايس
موتتش وكذلك وزير الامن القومي بيني جانز
وا
وزير الامن القومي تمار بنفير عفوا وبيني
جانس يريد حقيقه في هذا السياق ان يعقد
جلسات تتعلق بمساله مناقشه ما بعد الحرب
على اعتبار ان الاداره الامريكيه تدفع في
هذا السياق لانه لا يمكن لاسرائيل ان تخوض
حربا بدون ان تطع استراتيجيه وافق سياسي
لانهاء هذه الحرب كما ان بيني جانس من اشد
ربما الداعيين الى الانتقال الى المرحله
الثالثه في خضم العمليه البريه ومساله
اعاده الانتشار في فيما ان بنيامين
نتنياهو كما كان واضحا في هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي يسعى الى اطاله امد الحرب لانه
كلما طالت الحرب كلما بقي هو على سده
الحكم وعلى كرسي رئاسه الوزراء وهذه نقطه
في غايه الاهميه بنيامين نتنياهو سئل
الكثير من الاسئله فيما يتعلق بجوانب
الحرب وباعتقادي كان اهمها السؤال الذي
وجه له حول محور فيلادلفيا هذه المنطقه
الحدوديه بين قطاع غزه وا مصر وكان جواب
بنيامين نتنياهو واضحا وصريحا في هذه
المساله وقال بان محور فيلادلفيا يجب ان
يكون بيد اسرائيل لذلك بنيامين نتنياهو
يؤكد كل التوقعات العسكريه بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي في مرحله ما من عمر هذه الحرب
سوف يقوم باحتلال هذه المنطقه الحدوديه
بين قطاع غزه ومصر لكن هذه مساله ما من شك
في انها تحتاج الى كثير من التنسيق مع
الجانب المصري او على الاقل اعلام الجانب
المصري قبل البدء بشرو والشروع بعمليه
عسكريه ان كان حقيقه بنيامين نتنياهو يسعى
الى السيطره على هذه المنطقه لكن واضح
بانه بالرؤيه العسكريه على الاقل هنالك من
يدفع سياسيا ايضا في هذا الاطار انه لا
يمكن لاسرائيل ان تحقق اهداف حربها
بالقضاء على حركه حماس عسكريا ونزع سلاحها
وجعل قطاع غزه منطقه منزوعه السلاح بدون
السيطره على هذه المنطقه والنقطه الثانيه
المهمه في اي لقاء بنيامين نتنياهو وفي
حديثه كانت التطرق الى الى ايران وهو قال
بان اسرائيل تعمل ضد ايران في كل الطرق
وهو قال انا لا اريد ان افصل في هذا
السياق لكن كان واضحا بانه اكثر مما يلمح
الى ان اسرائيل مسؤوله عن عمليات الاغتيال
التي وقعت على الاراضي السوريه ضد
واستهدفت شخصيات اي عسكريه ايرانيه في
الايام القليله الماضيه وربما تلميحات الى
ابعد من ذلك كان ايضا اشار اليها في
الايام الاخيره وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
يوف جلاند في مسائله امام لجنه الخارجيه
والامن التابعه للكنيست عندما فهم بان
اسرائيل تعمل ربما على الاراضي الايرانيه
في اطار هذه الحرب متعدده الجبهات فيما دا
ذلك بنيامين نتنياهو عاد واكد على ان هذه
الحرب ستطول لاشهر كما استمعنا قبل قليل
حتى تحقيق اهدافها الموضوعه لها وهي
القضاء على حركه حماس عسكريا وسلطوية
ايجابيه لكنه قال لا نريد ان نوزع الامال
في هذه المساله لكن اشار في في نفس السياق
الى ان الضغط العسكري والعمليه العسكريه
ال المتواصله هي ربما تكون احد الطرق
لتحقيق هذا الهدف ب استعاده الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في داخل قطاع غزه
اذا كثير من من العناوين المهمه وهذه ربما
جمله من اهم ما جاء في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
benin nano